[Musique]
si nous et thomas sont de jeunes
trentenaires fiers de leur artisanat la
coutellerie
un travail de précision où la matière
prend forme sous leurs doigts véritable
créateur ils ont conçu et réalisé un
couteau originale qui s'inscrit dans
leur territoire tout simplement à taulé
le chinon le chinon c'est un coteau qui
est assemblé ici dans nos ateliers
il est différenciée par deux guillochage
différents et nous allons également 30
essences de bois différentes on
travaille également la corde sur le
manche le bois de cerf la corne de
buffle essentiellement fruit d'une année
de recherches et de travail
le chinon est l'aboutissement d'un long
parcours commencé dans la restauration
une reconversion dans l'artisanat assez
naturel pour les deux compères qui ont
su allier leurs compétences et leur
savoir faire
je vais plutôt m'intéresser à tous qui
va cuisiner âge d'acier donc la suite
acheter l'âme le guillochage des manches
sinon lui est plutôt spécialisé dans le
façonnage du bois donc les plaquettes et
la réalisation des étuis en cuir
également ce qui fait la qualité de leur
travail
c'est l'attention qu'il porte en matière
et au geste précis un savoir faire
unique en touraine
on s'imagine que les gens vont pouvoir
associer à chinon un couteau en plus
quoi couteau régionales c'est ce qu'on
souhaite n'est vraiment apporté à cette
région aux territoires chinonais un
petit peu notre savoir-faire en
coutellerie et apporter à ce patrimoine
encore une pièce est un élément en plus
du vin et tout un tas de choses qui se
font dans la région dès le mois de
janvier le chinon
or à son tire bouchon de quoi ravir les
amateurs du chinon qui ouvriront leurs
bouteilles de vin avec un chinon